>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN IS MEETING
WITH UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
WELL, MR. PRESIDENT, IT'S GOOD
TO HAVE YOU BACK.
I'M DELIGHTED YOU WERE ABLE TO
MAKE THE TRIP TO BE HERE, AND
YOU KNOW, IT'S AN HONOR TO BE BY
YOUR SIDE IN THE UNITED DEFENSE
AGAINST WHAT IS A BRUTAL, BRUTAL
WAR WAGED BY PUTIN.
300 DAYS, HARD TO BELIEVE, 300
DAYS GOING THROUGH THIS, AND
PUTIN HAS WAGED A BRUTAL ASSAULT
ON THE UKRAINIANS' RIGHT TO
EXIST AS A NATION, AND THE
ATTACK ON INNOCENT UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE FOR NO REASON OTHER THAN
TO INTIMIDATE.
AND HE'S ESCALATED HIS ASSAULT
ON CIVILIANS AFTER SCHOOLS,
ORPHANAGES, HOSPITALS,
LANDMARKS, IT'S JUST -- AND HE'S
TRYING TO USE WINTER AS A
WEAPON, AND BUT THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO INSPIRE THE
WORLD.
I MEAN THAT SINCERELY.
NOT JUST INSPIRE US, BUT INSPIRE
THE WORLD WITH THEIR COURAGE AND
HOW THEY HAVE CHOSE THEIR
RESILIENCE AND RESOLVE FOR THEIR
FUTURE, AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HAVE STOOD PROUDLY WITH THEM,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES IN
EUROPE AND JAPAN AND OTHER
PLACES TO MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE
FINANCIAL, HUMANITARIAN, AND
SECURITY ASSISTANCE THAT IS
NEEDED.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT
TODAY, AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE UKRAINE'S ABILITY TO
DEFEND ITSELF, PARTICULARLY AIR
DEFENSE, AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
GOING TO BE PROVIDING UKRAINE
WITH PATRIOT MISSILE BATTERY,
AND TRAINING YOUR FORCES TO BE
ABLE TO ACCURATELY USE IT.
TOGETHER WITH OUR PARTNERS,
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO IMPOSE COSTS
ON THE KREMLIN AND WILL SUPPORT
UKRAINE IN PURSUING A JUST
PEACE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OF THE
UNITED STATES STANDS WITH THE
BRAVE PEOPLE IN UKRAINE.
WE STAND WITH YOU, YOU'VE BEEN A
GREAT LEADER, AND BY THE WAY, WE
HAVE A FAMOUS THING THAT OCCURS
ONCE A YEAR, WE PICK THE MAN OF
THE YEAR IN TIME MAGAZINE, YOU
ARE THE MAN OF THE YEAR IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SO WELCOME.
WE HAVE A LOT TO TALK ABOUT.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MR. PRESIDENT, GREAT HONOR FOR
ME TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INVITATION.
I REALLY WANTED TO COME.
MR. PRESIDENT KNOWS I COULDN'T
DO IT BECAUSE THE SITUATION WAS
SO DIFFICULT.
NOW I CAME, WE CONTROLLED THE
SITUATION AND BECAUSE OF
SUPPORT, AND FIRST OF ALL
BECAUSE OF YOUR SUPPORT AND I
REALLY -- I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE IMPORTANT TOPICS AND WE'LL
DISCUSS THEM EVERYTHING SO MANY
CHALLENGES IN UKRAINE, IN
EUROPE, IN THE WORLD, AND FROM
ENERGY TO THE SITUATION ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, BUT REALLY ALL MY
APPRECIATIONS FROM MY HEART,
FROM THE HEART OF UKRAINIANS,
ALL UKRAINIANS, FROM OUR NATION,
STRONG NATION, ALL TO YOU, FIRST
OF ALL, MR. PRESIDENT FOR YOUR
BIG SUPPORT AND LEADERSHIP.
BECAUSE HELPED US AND ARE
HELPING NOW BECAUSE THE WAR IS
NOT OVER.
ANYWAY, BUT THAT IS YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU, FIRST OF ALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE THANKS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT, THANKS CONGRESS, AND
THANKS FROM JUST ORDINARY PEOPLE
TO YOUR ORDINARY PEOPLE,
AMERICANS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE.
I THINK IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS WHEN WE
SAY APPRECIATE, BUT YOU REALLY
HAD TO FEEL IT AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE.
AND YESTERDAY I WAS ON DONBAS,
THAT IS THE PLACE ON THE EAST OF
OUR COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW ALL THE DETAILS.
WE HAD SO MANY PHONE CALLS, AND
I WANT TO GIVE YOU SOMETHING.
ONE GUY WHO'S REALLY, REALLY A
HERO, REAL CAPTAIN, AND HE ASKED
ME TO PASS HIS AWARD, AND HE
ASKED ME TO PASS HIS AWARD TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE WILL UNDERSTAND HE IS THE
CAPTAIN OF HEIMERS BATTERY.
HE'S VERY BRAVE AND HE SAID GIVE
IT TO VERY BRAVE PRESIDENT, AND
I WANT TO GIVE YOU THAT IS A
CROSS FOR MILITARY MERIT.
THAT IS ONE.
>> GOD LOVE YOU.
>> YES.
THAT IS FROM HIM, AND I HAVE THE
LIST, HEAR ALL THE LIST.
YES, I DIDN'T READ, MR.
PRESIDENT.
IT'S IN UKRAINIAN LANGUAGE, BUT
HERE THAT TRANSLATION.
>> AND HIS NAME IS -- I HAVE HIS
NAME I COULD CONTACT HIM?
>> YES, YES.
PAVLO.
>> UNDESERVED BUT MUCH
APPRECIATED, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK
YOU.
>> HE SAID THAT ALL -- MANY HIS
BROTHERS THIS SYSTEM SAVED, SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WELL, WE HAVE A TRADITION
HERE, AND I WILL GIVE IT TO HIM,
MY SON WHO FOUGHT IN IRAQ, THEY
HAVE WHAT THEY CALL A COMMAND
COIN.
HAVE YOU SEEN THOSE COINS WE GET
IN THE BATTLEFIELD?
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT HE GETS
ONE OF THOSE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
WHAT A GREAT HONOR.
GREAT HONOR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, PRESS.
.
>> ALL RIGHT, PRESIDENT BIDEN
THERE WELCOMING IN PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY OF UKRAINE.
WE SAW, OF COURSE, PRESIDENT
BIDEN CONTINUE THE COMMITMENT OF
THE UNITED STATES TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE IN ITS FIGHT AGAINST
THIS RUSSIAN INVASION THAT HAS
GONE NOW MORE THAN 300 DAYS, AND
FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
BRINGING, AS HE SAID, HIS
APPRECIATION, ALL MY
APPRECIATION AND ALL THE
APPRECIATION OF THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE AND THEN PASSING ON FROM
A CAPTAIN THAT HE WAS VISITING
WITH YESTERDAY THIS CROSS FOR
MILITARY MERIT.
LET'S BRING BACK IN CNN'S CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PHIL
MATTINGLY WHO WAS THERE IN THE
ROOM, SENIOR INTERNATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT, WILL RIPLEY IN
KYIV, FORMER U.S. AMBASSADOR TO
UKRAINE, STEVE PIFER AND MIKE
LYONS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD SEND
THE COMMAND COIN BACK TO THAT
CAPTAIN, BUT ALSO THE QUITE
OBVIOUS AND GENUINE APPRECIATION
FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THIS CROSS
THAT HE RECEIVED FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT DID YOU SEE THERE IN THE
ROOM?
>> YEAH, IT WAS NOT EXPECTED.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT IN TERMS OF
BRINGING FOLKS AS WE WALKED OUT
OF THE OVAL OFFICE, I THINK IT
WAS ABSOLUTELY AS YOU HEARD FROM
THE PRESIDENT, HE SAID
UNDESERVED BUT VERY APPRECIATED.
IT'S ALSO A VERY PERSONAL TOUCH
TO A VERY REAL TRAGEDY THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS DEALING
WITH ON A DAY-TO-DAY BASIS IN
HIS COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY ALLUDED TO
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THEM.
THEY SPEAK ON THE PHONE
CONSTANTLY.
THEY HAVE VIDEO CONFERENCES
FAIRLY REGULARLY.
THIS IS THEIR FIRST FACE-TO-FACE
MEETING AND ADDING THAT PERSONAL
ELEMENT TO WHAT ARE EXPECTED TO
BE INTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS OVER
THE NEXT TWO HOURS, I THINK IS A
LEVEL OF UNDERSTANDING OF I
THINK PERSONALLY HOW PRESIDENT
BIDEN OPERATES AND KIND OF THE
DEPTH IN WHICH HE APPROACHES
ISSUES AND MOMENTS LIKE THIS,
BUT ALSO, A RECOGNITION OF THE
NECESSITY OF DISPLAYING THIS TO
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AS WELL.
SO MUCH OF THIS TRIP IS THE
OBVIOUS SYMBOLISM, THE OBVIOUS
PARALLELS PERHAPS TO, YOU KNOW,
THE CHURCHILL SPEECH TO CONGRESS
IN THE FEW DAYS AFTER PEARL
HARBOR, BUT ALSO IT UNDERSCORES
THE MOMENT THAT UKRAINE IS IN IN
A WAR THAT IS VERY MUCH AT A
STALEMATE MOMENT RIGHT NOW WHERE
MORE ASSISTANCE WILL BE NEEDED,
MORE COMMITMENT WILL BE NEEDED
AT THE SAME TIME THAT THE
WESTERN COALITION THAT HAS STOOD
STEADFASTLY BEHIND THEM IS
WITHOUT QUESTION DEALING WITH
THEIR OWN INDIVIDUAL DOMESTIC
ISSUE.
THERE'S A VERY REAL CONCERN
ABOUT SOME LEVEL OF EXHAUSTION
ON THE SIDE OF THE COALITION'S
PART, AND SO MAKING SURE THAT
THE ACTUAL REALITIES ON THE
GROUND AND WHAT HE CAN BRING TO
HELP DEMONSTRATE THAT I THINK
WAS CRITICAL GIVEN NOT JUST
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT SEVERAL
HOURS, WHICH WILL BE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, BUT ALSO WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS, VICTOR.